hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control sc.l
2-3.13.10 establish and manage
cryptographic keys for cryptography
employed in organizational systems
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
is feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all of this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload I've got great news for you uh
you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance hero like a
caterpillar into a butterfly baby that's
what we're doing let's jump into it this
is an interesting control as it
essentially is mandating good and proper
housekeeping this requirement emphasizes
the importance of implementing
appropriate key management practices to
ensure the security of cryptographic
operations the control requires
organizations to define specific
requirements for key generation
distribution storage access and
destruction by following these
requirements organizations can
effectively manage cryptographic keys
and maintain the security of their
systems let's take a look in plain
English version of what the assessors
are looking for on this one all right
two things one determine if
cryptographic keys are established
whenever cryptography is employed again
we would say this is implant the IT team
manages all cryptographic keys a lot of
times this is done in active directory
or Azure active directory uh sometimes
it's done through other methods but
again you just have to show them that
you have a method second assessment
point is determine if cryptographic keys
are managed uh whenever cryptography is
employed implemented it team manages all
cryptographic keys
pretty simple and straightforward stuff
again every company is going to have a
little bit of an individual scenario on
this uh the most common one I think is
going to be active directory uh you know
type passwords and things like that so
again active directory for the most part
really does this in an automated way now
uh if you were banging your head against
the wall and are kind of listening to
our videos and thinking to yourself man
uh this is a lot easier than trying to
figure this out on my own great because
hey that's what we do here at on call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this defars nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped in
their laps like a Serial on a sunny day
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminated gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc complianceecrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out here for you
you help us out with a big thumbs up on
that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance words roll it out until our
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]